bonjour antoine karam
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france vous revenez de
guyane si je ne me trompe vous
confirmerez à quelle est la situation
sur place
la situation est compliquée complexe
difficile la pandémie s'accélère c'est
dans un contexte extrêmement compliqué
difficile que le ministre d outre mer et
en guyane depuis samedi pour une visite
de quatre jours jusqu'à marty alors
justement il a déjà rencontré un le
personnel de l'hôpital de cayenne
notamment pour faire la pédagogie de la
vaccination alors comment ce message a
été reçu a été perçue en guyane
l'inquiétude est grande il faut le
reconnaître donc les ministres viennent
ils font des annonces et après est ce
qu'elle se comptait certain qu'un autre
sujet
là je ne peux pas être en mesure
aujourd'hui de vous dire comment est
perçue la déclaration du ministre mais
au delà de la question de la vaccination
et de la pédagogie qu'il a pu faire
durant son séjour notamment au centre
hospitalier de cayenne la réalité est
qu'il faut des moyens supplémentaires
quand vous savez comme moi que la guyane
est un véritable des ermites médicale et
que un pays où le taux de pandémie
dépasse aujourd'hui le taux d'incidence
plus de 500 pour 1000 habitants fait
qu'il faut aujourd'hui faire revenir en
guyane un hôpital de campagne avec des
moyens supplémentaires tant humains que
matériels alors des moyens
supplémentaires mais ce qu'on a du mal à
comprendre de métropole
c'est cette dichotomie entre des
personnels soignants qui se disent
absolument débordée et ce refus relative
de se faire vacciner comment est ce que
il voit les choses en métropole où la
situation s'améliore
alors la situation s'améliore en france
hexagonale certes mais n'oubliez pas que
la guyane est un territoire assez
particulier en amérique du sud avec deux
frontières qui font total 1250 km de
frontières avec des gens qui rentrent et
qui sortent comme est comme ça leur
semble
les jours tous les jours on ne peut pas
comparer la guyane de la france
hexagonale une campagne de vaccination a
commencé il faut donner un peu de temps
au temps pour que les gens puissent
accepter ce principe et c'est en cela
que les autorités en tous les cas
guyanaise locales les responsables
politiques dans leur grande majorité ont
demandé qu'il y ait un moratoire le
temps que sur le plan comme il l'a
souhaité le faire pédagogique il puisse
convaincre les personnels soignants de
guyane acer vacciner afin que la
situation s'améliore dans les semaines
qui viennent au vu de l'urgence est ce
que vous seriez favorable à une
fermeture de la frontière avec le brésil
dont on sait que le pays est très
touchée aussi par l'épidémie mais
monsieur la frontière est fermée sa
férule à la terre entière en guyane
comment pouvez vous fermez 750 km de
frontière même en mettant un militaire
un gendarme tous les 50 mètres vous
savez que les anciens clubs de tout
temps et les frontières ne peuvent pas
être chez elles sont fermées de façon
théorique mais sur le plan pratique il y
à une circulation des biens des
personnes en permanence 24 heures sur 24
alors ça n'est pas là qu'il faut agir il
faut agir autrement mettre les moyens là
où il faut et me tiens à la frontière
franco-brésilienne à la frontière franco
surinamienne des moyens le le choc par
exemple ces 8 8 8 lits en réanimation
pour un hôpital aussi important récent
et qui n'a pas les moyens de sa
politique il faut agir autrement il faut
agir mieux il faut être plus efficace et
ce sont des moyens qui nous manque la
guyane est une histoire de retard
structurel avec ces questions sanitaires
en vue amène tous les moyens qui doivent
être mis aujourd'hui doivent se
concentrer sur les moyens humains et les
moyens matériels alors ça c'est sûrement
plus un problème récurrent vous le
disiez vienne est un désert médical vous
pensez que la visite du ministre va
enfin changer les choses
vous savez j'espère les gouvernements se
succèdent mais c'est l'état qui est en
ligne de mire quels que soient les
gouvernements
il faut agir vite avant et vous savez
comme moi que
toute force politique confondue avec les
gouvernements qui se sont succédé il ya
un accord maintenant signée ap pour la
question d'un chu qui donnerait qu'il
permettrait à l'as interglobe de
franchir un saut qualitatif mais vous
savez que le chu ne sera pas
opérationnel avant
2025 c'est à dire 4 encore une chose
qu'il faut atteindre il faut donc
aujourd'hui cherche vite et de mieux
dans le contexte de dégradation
sanitaire que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui nous sommes il n'est plus
urgent d'attendre aujourd'hui en guyane
il est urgent d'agir alors aux deux cas
lorsque le ministre partira mercredi et
qu'il sera au conseil des ministres
merkel mercredi il aura l'occasion de
parler au premier ministre et au
président de la république de la
situation qui ne cesse de se dégrader
rural et de prendre des dispositions
pour inverser la tendance merci beaucoup
à antoine karam d'avoir répondu à nos
questions ce matin sur rtl france je le
rappelle vous êtes ancien président du
conseil régional de guyane ancien
sénateur